[Music]
welcome to kubernetes security the easy
way my name's Aaron small and also today
we'll have Greg and CJ software
engineers on the gke security team
ostensibly we're here to talk about GCE
security but really this talk is about
trust
when you choose gke or any cloud
provider to host your product you're
placing your trust in them
in us I don't know about you but I can't
open the news without reading some
headline about information security
it's a cyberattack or the latest breach
of sensitive information which to those
people impacted is just one more breach
of trust software security is something
we all have to care about today but too
many it can feel like a distraction from
doing what's most important which is
building your product and delighting
your customers we're passionate about
software security we get up every day
delighted by the prospect of finding
that vulnerability before the bad guys
do and building the tools people can use
to build state-of-the-art secure
applications there are lots of talks and
blogs and white papers you can read
that'll talk about how to harden your
kubernetes cluster talk about common
attacks or highlight recent compromises
this talk is not about that like I said
this talk is about trust and in my
experience the best way to build trust
is to be transparent so we're giving you
a backstage pass into the work we do at
Google behind the scenes under embargoes
and even before you build your first
container to keep your cluster as secure
as possible for those of you who are
familiar with gke it's not unlikely that
you think of it as simply a managed
kubernetes control plane and you might
infer from that that the security we
provide stops there while we do take
control plane security quite seriously
that's not the end of it Greg and CJ
will discuss how we secure your gke
nodes the control plane and the tools
that we've built that you have at your
disposal for attack detection and
vulnerability mitigation CJ also has a
demo that'll demonstrate a potential
compromised scenario and how the tools
we built make it easy to respond and
mitigate okay most of you have probably
seen a diagram like this before so
please forgive the early morning Shiki
101
I do want to give a little bit of
groundwork though for the rest of the
presentation gke in its simplest terms
is a hosted kubernetes control plane and
some number of kubernetes nodes you the
developers and administrators interact
with the control plane and your users
interact with the containers that you've
deployed on the notes the control plane
manages your workloads it manages what
nodes belong to the cluster and the
certificate authority that handles
authentication of the node agents also
called couplets the nodes themselves
execute containers receive configuration
data secrets etcetera that they need the
function from the control plan it's on
those nodes where the aforementioned
hardening guides and best practices come
into play as you get more familiar with
kubernetes you'll customize this and
configure it and really make it your own
it can get as complex and as unique as
you want to make it the security of this
space follows the shared responsibility
model meaning we're responsible for the
security of the infrastructure itself
and you're responsible for what you
deploy there you manage among other
things the node specification which has
all the standard VM knobs you might
expect a number of cores a number of
amount of RAM the operating system
whether or not that's a GPU attached
what services and workloads you've
deployed there and any Google Cloud
service accounts that you use to talk to
other Google cloud services but today
we're talking about what Google does for
you so with that I want to hand off to
Greg who's going to discuss node
security thanks Aaron so I'm gonna start
out the behind the scenes to talking
about node security I'm gonna build this
picture up in a few different layers so
we're gonna start at the VM for visiting
layout there's been a number of other
Google talks in the past about the great
security work Google's doing below that
layer things like hardware and firmware
security I'm gonna skip that in favor of
kind of covering new material and making
sure we get to kubernetes stuff so
starting at the virtual machine layer
then operating system on top then the
cubelet and
how we bootstrapped the trust in that
system and finally the system containers
that make up kubernetes and other Google
containers that we run so starting at
the VM provisioning layer so when you
create a cluster with GK you get nodes
that are automatically provisioned into
a virtual private cloud we create a
firewall that has just enough privilege
for the control plane be able to talk to
the nodes and notes to be able to talk
to each other the VMS have disks that
are encrypted at rest you can read all
about that at this link here and they
really benefit from a lot of work that
Google's done over the years to harden
our hypervisor so Google has spent a
large amount of security time making
sure that VM is running on that same
shared hardware are really well isolated
from each other and our vm's inherit all
that great work that Google's done
previously as an optional feature at the
moment it's it's currently beta you can
make your when you create a cluster you
can make it a private cluster and that
means that you essentially take it off
the public internet so your nodes get
private IP addresses RFC 1918 addresses
and one of you do that it's it's a good
I think when you don't need a service on
the internet it's always good to be able
to remove it from the internet now you
kind of take out a bunch of attacks
related to just kind of general internet
scanning so that's the virtual machine
layer so the next layer up is the
operating system so the default
operating system that we offer on GK
ease the container optimized OS we also
offer a bun to by canonical but in the
interests of time today I'm just
focusing on Cotton's canonical also does
it has a great security team and builds
a great OS but I'm talking about cause
today so this is an OS so it's built by
Google it's based on chromium OS it's a
really minimal OS it's really just
enough OS to run containers and not much
else and that's good because less code
means less vulnerabilities I mean less
attacks office less maintenance bird and
less patching and all that stuff is good
we've also spent a significant amount of
time hardening this operating system so
we've enabled a whole bunch of different
kernel security features and set a bunch
of secure defaults kind of at the kernel
layer and various other operating system
knobs and the idea there is to make that
initial execution step of any attack
much harder so if we can put in an
memory protection in the kernel that
makes it harder for attackers to execute
that's that's a win we've also spent
quite a bit of time trying to make it
harder to persist through a number of
different mechanisms so things like an
immutable root filesystem making the
root filesystem read-only and having a
verified boot chain means that a number
of this sort of traditional ways to
persist on an operating system are made
much harder on cause we're also enabling
features like EBP F to allow third party
security products particularly detection
products to run on GK we want those
products to work well on GK and this
more work you can do here if you want to
go the extra mile so second cause also
supports seccomp and a palma so you can
really kind of write a very specific
hardening for your particular
application if you'd like to go that far
into it you can kind of define the
normal behavior of your application and
the idea there is that if an attacker is
trying to operate outside the bounds of
what is normal for your application then
it should be blocked by these
technologies and make their life a lot
harder and you can read more about cause
and all the kind of hardening and
security work we're doing there at this
dress and for all of these like little
lengths that on firing up on the screen
here I have a giant slide at the end
with a big list so I if you just want to
take a photo of that one you can I also
briefly wanted to mention the team
behind cause so we have a dedicated team
that is working on maintenance testing
security patching we're also have a lot
of Google in-house Linux kernel
expertise so that benefits the whole
Linux ecosystem those people are
developing new kernel security features
and also finding vulnerabilities and
patching them but we're also
benefiting from that expertise with
cause so we're driving features through
the kernel and into calls that we're
making use of so I'll just give you a
second to absorb this diagram or you're
up to the next level now so we've got VM
OS and then on top of that is kubernetes
so there's a fairly simplified version
of how the cubelet bootstraps its trust
so we're gonna walk through this and
give you an idea of kind of how that
happens so what makes a kundunese node a
kubernetes node it's when you have a
cubelet that's registered with the API
server and kind of fennec aid to it so
we start down the bottom of this picture
with the node VM where the cubelets
running and it retrieves a bootstrap key
from the metadata server which is
running outside the VM but beside it so
it retrieves that key and then Nate
creates a certificate signing request
it's a standard x.509 certificate
signing request and sends that to the
api server the API server receives that
CSR and authentic checks that it's
authenticated with that bootstrap key it
does some of the checks on the csr
itself and then it sends it off a viral
web hook to signing api and that's
actually running outside the cluster so
that hosted control plane is running on
a GCE VM and the Google products is you
may have heard of Borg
our internal infrastructure so that's 98
guys and keys are held externally so
that call goes out to that API the
certificate request gets signed and this
propagates back to the cubelet and the
interesting part of all this is that the
signing keys are actually held
externally to the cluster so we have an
extra trust boundary in between those
two so properties of this this procedure
the traffic's all authenticated and
encrypted the trust comes from the
virtual machine we end up with a per
node x.509 identity which is actually
really important CJ will talk later
about how this is useful in control
plane security with the node authorizer
I mentioned the CA is off the cluster
and in the future we're looking at how
we can improve this bootstrapping
process in kubernetes 111 where my team
contributed some code that will allow
the cupola to bootstrap itself using a
trusted platform module and the idea
there is that you will the couplet will
no longer have to handle the key
material directly so that will be a
security win so once we have a cubelet
that isn't all that we need for the
cluster there's a bunch of other cluster
services that need to run
so there's kubernetes things like queue
proxy cluster dns and there's also
Google extra add-ons like logging
containers modern monitoring containers
as well as things like they contain a
runtime so Google does a lot of work to
maintain these make sure they're working
make sure they work with the control
plane and make sure they scale
appropriately but there's the security
relevant pieces are that we deliver
these in a defensible configuration that
you wouldn't find things like a
container runtime plot listening on the
open Internet for example we also look
at the security of all these containers
regularly so we're scanning the
containers referenced and of kubernetes
source code for vulnerabilities and
we're patching those where where patches
are missing so that's kind of what we do
with those containers there's actually
some work here for you the GAE user to
do with these containers as well so you
really need to be able to upgrade your
nodes to get those patches so I just
talked about the security patching
process essentially how that works is we
will patch the container release a new
version of the container and then update
kubernetes to reference that new version
of the container and when we do that
we'll bump the node version so the way
so that a node upgrades is essentially
the like the rising tide that lifts the
container ship that has all the
containers on it so to make that process
easier there's actually an auto upgrade
feature that you can opt into so you can
say Google please handle the upgrades of
these nodes automatically I don't want
to think about it and to give you some
control over when that happens you can
actually specify maintenance windows so
that's a four-hour window
let's say this to Google hey please do
your upgrade your maintenance toss
within this window so that's node
security we talked about the improve
visioning in terms of hypervisor
firewalls the operating system kernel
hardening security patching kubernetes
trust bootstrap in terms of how the CA
works and the system containers and how
they're patched and upgraded the
takeaway I'd like you to take from this
section is that Google's doing a whole
bunch of work here so that you don't
have to care about any of this and you
can focus on your application but the
one thing you do need to do is look
after your node upgrades so I'm going to
hand it over to CJ to talk about control
plane security
thanks Greg hmm so Greg gave us a good
overview of what GK provides you in
terms of the manage note environment but
a lot of what you think of of the
security that GK provides you is the
manage kubernetes control plane so on
gke each cluster control plane is
separated by a VM boundary from every
other cluster control plane so that
means that the API server that you
talked to is entirely yours the at CD
database that houses your kubernetes api
resources is all yours and then the
add-ons that run in your cluster are all
yours the kubernetes api that you talk
to is the same kubernetes that you would
get running at yourself but on gke
that's all managed by google so a big
part of that isolation is the per
cluster certificate authority Greg
mentioned it it governs the node
credentials that the node agents use to
authenticate to the manage control plane
it also governs the server-side
credentials that the manage control
plane authenticates itself with the key
for that as Greg mentioned is held off
the cluster for defense-in-depth
encrypted at rest the fact that it is a
per cluster CA means that we get a
simplified chain of trust we don't
depend on a public CA or PKI for this to
work and then that key is rotatable on
demand either just for good hygiene or
as part of an incident response so Greg
mentioned the per node identity that you
get as part of that cubelet trust
bootstrap and that per node identity
becomes super important when we start
thinking about how nodes interact with
the managed control plane to manage what
they're actually what workloads they're
actually running so node agents have
only the permissions they need to do
their job so that means that one node is
only allowed to update status about
itself and it's only allowed to see
things like secrets and config maps that
are actually pertinent to the workloads
that it that are scheduled onto it and
this is just another
defense-in-depth step that that helps
make a compromise of OneNote stay
limited to just that node so another
huge benefit you get from the managed
control plane that GK gives you is the
seamless authentication with the same
user accounts that you already have on
Google Cloud so whether you are taking a
look at usage or digging through logs in
the cloud console or you're on the
command line debugging your kubernetes
application using G cloud and cute
control you're the you're the same user
with the same strong authentication that
you get anywhere else from Google Cloud
building on top of that authentication
story Google gke is integrated with
Google like I am which which gives you
the ability to manage the permissions
grant your team just the permissions
they need to do their job and then see
and enforce that policy in one place
across your entire organization for
advanced kubernetes users this all plays
nice with kubernetes are back for access
control so now that you know who is
supposed to be able to do what it's
still really helpful to have that audit
trail after the fact to see what
actually happened so the pertinent info
you want on gke is what what is access
the kubernetes api and also what
operations have taken place on the
underlying gke clusters so if you've
ever been in a situation where you you
had an incident and then you looked
after the fact just to realize that you
forgot to turn on logs while on GCP we
give you four hundred days of retention
of what we call admin activity logs by
default so that's mutating operations so
on gke that's things like creating new
kubernetes pods or upgrading the version
of your of your gke nodes for everything
else for things like read access to the
to the kubernetes api you can enable
data access logs and those get retained
for 30 days you those get ingested
directly to stackdriver where you can
analyze them there if you have another
tool that you that you
like to analyze your logs with you can
easily export logs from stackdriver
using something like cloud pub/sub so to
show off how powerful all of these
features can be together I'm going to
set up a little demo scenario so we're
gonna say that we have this continuous
integration continuous deployment system
that every hour it's going to build a
new version of our application and it's
gonna it's going to then push that
application artifacts up to Google Cloud
Storage and then once that's done we're
going to deploy the new version of our
application out to our GK cluster for
some testing so that's all good we've
got that running and then one day we get
the the dreaded email Google has
detected that so some credential from
our project appears to have been exposed
somewhere on the public Internet we dig
back a little bit and sure enough we
accidentally checked in our private key
to a public source control repo so what
that means is that the deploy piece of
the CI CD system we set up is now using
a credential that that has access to a
gke cluster and that credential may be
exposed somewhere so how would we
respond to this so let's pop over to the
cloud console and walk through some of
our options so the first thing you would
want to do in this scenario is pop into
the IAM service accounts tab and rotate
that key and you do that just by coming
over here to create a new key provision
that out to the system that needs it so
that so that you can take this without
any downtime and then you delete the key
that that we saw was compromised I'm not
going to do that yet for the sake of
demonstration we're actually going to
walk through what could have happened in
this situation so the next thing we want
to take a look at is what permissions
did that service account actually have
so if we go into the permissions tab we
can see that our CI CD pipeline service
account here we granted it the CI CD
pipeline role and now what that is is
actually an iam custom role so if I pop
over to the custom roles tab you'll be
able to see where I did
find the CI CD pipeline role and
clicking into that we see that the only
two permissions contained in that role
are the ability to get deployments and
the ability to update deployments we
have a very simplified CI CD system all
it's doing is updating the container
version to point to the new application
we just built now deployments that
update is still a fairly elevated
permission it allows you like I just
mentioned to change the container image
or to even change parameters or the
environment that your application is
running in so we're not completely out
of the woods yet but by limiting these
permissions to exactly what this thing
needs to get its job done we've at least
limited the surface area of the
potential attack so now that we've seen
what this thing could do let's go ahead
and take a look at what it has done so
if we pop over to the stack driver logs
and we look at the kubernetes logs we
see it's fairly noisy the kubernetes api
is a pretty noisy place there's a lot of
activity going on luckily in this
stackdriver UI we can we can easily
filter this by a text search we know our
service account had CI CD in it and we
see that the thing that's happened so
far is mostly what we expect it's our
it's our hourly push to our gke cluster
so so far so good we can we can dig in
here find some interesting information
in this we can even start streaming the
logs so that we see new activity as it
happens so let's switch gears a little
bit and think about what this might look
like from a potential attacker scenario
so a common way you you might see this
happen is an attacker might write a very
shallow broad script that's just
scanning the internet for anything that
looks like credentials then you might
take a really quick attempt at trying to
make use of those credentials trying to
make money off that probably by by
implanting a malicious application
somewhere so I've written up a little
script that's just gonna
pretend to scan the internet for keys so
everything you see in Wyatt is sort of
pretend stuff but the things that are in
green are actual commands and then and
then the things that are in red are the
responses from those commands so we're
gonna we're gonna scan the internet for
keys and sure enough it came across our
exposed service account key for that CIC
D pipeline
so the next thing it'll do is configure
the shell to make use of those
credentials and we're gonna go ahead and
attempt to implant our malicious
application as a kubernetes pod in this
cluster and you'll see that luckily that
that request was denied so the error we
got back from kubernetes is that we did
not have enough permissions to make this
request if you remember back to the I am
custom role we took a look at we had the
ability to get deployments and update
deployments but we didn't have the
ability to create pods so that's good so
maybe this script tries to create these
things a couple more times but it's
gonna it's gonna fail every time and if
this is just a shallow cheap scan maybe
it just moves on and and we were lucky
that we we got safe there now if you
were watching over here on the right you
saw these logs start to pop up and so in
this scenario it's fairly obvious to see
where the anomalous activity came in
from in other incidents it may not be
this easy you know we can directly see
that this double exclamation point red
thing got an error we can dig into how
exactly that happened but in real
incidents you might you might have
better luck
analyzing logs further here or exporting
them to a different system to do more
in-depth processing that's as easy as
creating an export you can send that to
bigquery give it a name create the sync
I've already done that so let's pop over
to this bigquery tab where I've stream
blogs to a bigquery data set I've
already written out a query I'm gonna
take a look for any calls that have come
from this service account but they came
from outside what I'm gonna pretend is
our corporate IP range we
our CI CD system is is only going to be
calling from this IP range that we
expect so if we do see accesses from
this service account coming from
elsewhere we'd like to know that's
unusual and then just from that I'm
going to gather some some pertinent
information so we take a look at this
query and sure enough it's gonna pop up
with those three calls that that script
just made we see from the HTTP code our
attacker was unsuccessful
didn't have enough permissions and we we
have the IP of the caller right here
that can help inform some of our some of
our additional incident response so I'm
not going to go any deeper into incident
response here incidents are fairly
unique I just wanted to highlight some
of the tools that that we've provided
that help you help you start to begin
your incident response if you've ever
been in a situation like this you know
how critical it can be to get good solid
information quickly to stakeholders and
leadership so we walked through how GK
E's integration with with Google
authentication gives you a single place
to go manage and rotate your credentials
we saw how gke works with iam to grant
granular least privileged permissions
and set and enforce that across your org
and then lastly we saw how GK E's
automatic audit logging gives you the
ability to to have a solid incident
response story without without having to
have remembered to turn it on and with
that I'm gonna hand it back over to
Gregg who's going to talk through some
real-life examples of vulnerability
management in gke
thanks CJ so I wanted to talk a little
about vulnerability management and
something that often doesn't get a lot
of airtime and I wanted to do that with
some example case studies now these case
studies are just two examples in time I
think they're both interesting but not
every vulnerabilities gonna work out
like this each vulnerability tends to be
unique on a number of different axes so
with that caveat the first one I want to
talk about is some vulnerabilities that
were found in some software called DNS
mask it
back in October in 2017 so this is
open-source software it is a very well
used piece of software not written by
Google it's open-source and it provides
critical DNS services and other
networking services for many many
different companies it's very well used
it runs on laptops desktops servers into
IOT devices lots of different places so
I'm gonna step through kind of how the
vulnerability was found how we fixed it
and what the outcome was for G key so
how was this vulnerability found so
Google employs a bunch of really
world-class security researchers
internally they are focused on finding
vulnerabilities in our own products and
fixing them as well as finding
vulnerabilities and critical pieces of
Internet infrastructure and making the
internet safer so in this case well
actually and we also have the
vulnerability rewards program where we
engage the external security research
community and we pay them for their work
through a bug bounty program so in this
case for a DNS mask this was a Google
discovered vulnerability so a Google
security research have found a whole
series of vulnerabilities actually and
if you're interested in kind of geeking
out on the details of these
vulnerabilities you can go read all
about them here it's not really super
relevant for this presentation but there
was a the worst of them was a remote
connect code execution so our the Google
security researchers started working
with the maintainer of DNS mask who's a
external party doesn't work at Google
together they came up with a fix that
fix the vulnerabilities that had been
found and then we started a worldwide
kind of multi company coordinated
disclosure effort I was really
complicated kind of disclosures to try
and get a number of people as many
people patched as possible and we
enlisted the help of the u.s. cert the
u.s. computer emergency readiness team
with that effort so what did this mean
for gke so internally we we identified
the gke and kubernetes depended on dns
masks and that meant that we we knew we
were vulnerable and so we kicked off the
community's security response
and that starts with us emailing the
communities product security team which
we actually sit on as well too so that's
represented a handful of representatives
from companies at Google Microsoft Red
Hat
in this case CJ actually led the
vulnerability response so we volunteered
to take the lead in other cases it might
be someone from Microsoft or someone
from Red Hat all very experienced
security engineers with expert deep
expertise in kubernetes so we took the
lead on this one which was essentially
working out how to fix it in communities
so we figured out that we had to patch
cube DNS with this new fix that had been
developed with the DNS mask maintainer
and release a new version of that
container so and once we once we gotten
a the fix kind of settled we had to
build and staged it a number of releases
so the releases followed the security
release process which is extensively
documented at this list at this link you
can go read all about it
but essentially what we were able to do
is create kubernetes releases for three
different release branches and even
actually one more because one eight was
about to be released at the time all of
those contain we were able to patch all
those branches with the fix and release
the fix on the same day as the public
vulnerability went went out and for gke
this meant that as part of the managed
service we were able to make a change on
the masters that rolled out a change to
cube dns across the clusters and so the
outcome for GAE customers was that we
were able to patch this vulnerability at
the public release time with without any
action required on the part of the
customer so I think that's kind of the
ideal outcome that you know Google
spends a whole bunch of engineering
hours figuring out how to do all this
and just fixes it for everyone and you
don't even have to worry about it you
may not have even been aware of this
vulnerability it won't always work out
like that but I think that is the ideal
case the second case study I wanted to
talk about briefly is the specter in
meltdown vulnerabilities so this was
from January early January this year
so these were very interesting
vulnerabilities probably most of the
people in this room have heard about
them if you haven't they were discovered
by Google project zero they were
vulnerable these and most modern CPUs
they're caused by this speculative
execution feature I'm also not going to
dig in for the details of this if you do
want details there's an entire next
session that has actually already
happened but you can find it on YouTube
if you want to dig into how Google found
these vulnerabilities and how we fix
them across the whole infrastructure it
should be a really interesting talk
there's also a blog post and if you just
google these things you'll find out a
ton about theme it's they were very well
known so what did this mean for gke so
we knew that we had to make virtual
machine changes so that there was
changes necessary necessary to the
hypervisor to prevent 1vn accessing the
hosts memory of the of the hardware
machine that was running the VM and
getting access to another VM on the same
machine so we needed some hypervisor
changes to fix that problem and then as
a second layer of defense we also needed
some changes in the kernel enabling some
new protections there that required a
new version of the cause so that was
essentially a second layer of protection
and you'll hear Google security
engineers talk about two layers of
defense a lot so we're always looking
for a two layers of defense where we can
find them it doesn't always happen but
we our experience has told us that when
we can get two layers of defense that
that's a really good thing and it really
helps so there was lots of testing
involved many many hours of engineering
time spent on getting these fixes and
testing them testing upgrade pause
testing performance in particular
because these new kernel security
features had some significant
performance changes so the outcome for
gke I I think was actually pretty cool
so we were able to live migrate using
technology that GCE basically built so
we were able to take those nodes that
we're running customer workloads and
live migrate then launch that new
version of that hypervisor without any
interruption I think that's actually
pretty awesome I've given given the
scale of these vulnerabilities and how
come
they were there was still some customer
work required so the that upgrade to the
calls image did require a node upgrade
like I mentioned previously but we were
able to deliver kind of like that first
defense without any customer effort
required so in general how do we handle
kind of communications for security
patches and similar issues if there's a
serious security vulnerability we'll
send targeted emails if it requires an
action by the customer and for
everything else we have a security
bulletins page that you can see at this
link it has an RSS feed you can also
subscribe to all these links are at the
end - I also briefly wanted to mention
again the Google vulnerabilities reward
program so we've built on a lot of
success with this program with Android
chrome and and all the Google's web
properties and I just wanted to call out
specifically that it does apply to gke
it this is not a new announcement it has
been it has applied for a very long time
but this essentially gives us a false
multiplier for engaging that external
security research community and getting
vulnerabilities finding them new
vulnerabilities and fixing them as
quickly as possible so before I hand it
back to Aaron I just wanted to mention
be the key takeaway from that section I
think is that Google is doing a whole
bunch of work in vulnerability
management to make it as easy as
possible for you the customer it won't
always be zero zero effort on your
behalf but we were really trying to
minimize that effort that you need to
put in on those kind of annoying
problems with patterns under abilities
okay so I feel like we just shotgunned a
lot of content to you guys so I'm gonna
give a pretty brief recap Greg discussed
the layered approach that we take to gke
security all the way from VM
provisioning up to kubernetes
configuration CJ disgust control plane
security as well as gave us a demo of
how you might handle the compromise of a
sensitive secret and then Greg came back
and walk us through a couple of marquee
vulnerabilities over the last year or so
and how we manage them so what's the
point of all of this what message are we
sending what do we want you to take away
that's that software security is our
full-time job on gke and we want to give
to you that trust where the
infrastructure you need to build
state-of-the-art world-changing secure
applications this is a one of the photo
slides we have a ton of great container
security content and next some of this
has already happened so it'll be
available on YouTube I would highly
recommend going back and watching them
we also have met several more talks
today but I would definitely encourage
you to go visit if you care about
security I'll be at most of them if I
can and this is the link slide that Greg
reference before glad it's big enough
for you to read thank you that is all
the content that we have so far
you
[Music]